Kayal is with us in Indianapolis hey
Kyle welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks Dave are you better than I
deserve how can I help
I've got a question for you 20 years
baby step 2
my income has between one hundred
twenty-five hundred thirty thousand I've
got 25 grand in student loans the other
debt I have is a payment that I'm
required to have for my job you know
it's not you're not you are not required
to stop you're not required to have a
car payment in your job that's not true
I don't understand what you're saying I
said it you're I get it I get a car
allowance and they give me a certain set
of vehicles I know but they're not or
they don't require car payment they give
you a car allowance and they require
that you have a certain car
you chose to cause that to happen with a
car payment but they do not require a
car payment I took this job as I am now
so I didn't have you know thirty
thousand dollars safe have to go find
the vehicle so that was kind of my
question what your advice would be to
get to that point to where you're paying
cash for that vehicle when they require
me to get a new one every three years so
saving upon your requirement brand-new
no they don't they require you drive a
car that is not older than three years
old yeah so if you bought it three years
so I made a set of assumptions again you
got to stop that dude it's killing you
because you decided to go buy a $30,000
car and got yourself in a pinch and
you're destroying it because you live in
a car don't you
I do yeah and so whatever you drive you
are destroying its value you're a road
warrior and so you've got to this is a
business overhead problem you have
chosen to destroy a $30,000 vehicle when
you could have chosen to destroy a
$15,000 vehicle and still met all the
requirements and trade every year trade
once a year to year listen do you want
to destroy thirty thousand or fifteen
that's it so you get the minimum vehicle
that will do the job and meet their
requirements and that's going to be a
two-year-old vehicle you drive it for a
year run the wheels off the stinking
thing and it goes way down in value
because you're putting fifty thousand
miles on a car probably aren't you and I
could tell I mean that's this is who
requires you to do this kind of stuff is
people that run the wheels off cars and
so what do you what do you sell in
pharmaceutical sales no I'm selling
construction equipment good good okay
good well you're making Bank
you got a great career but don't take
these general guidelines they give you
and let that be an excuse for you to
lose this much money because you're
losing $15,000 a year on the transaction
you're talking about so you need to do
trade down in cars to a one two year old
car get the cheapest possible thing that
will do the job that's reliable and
comfortable you live in the car so needs
to be comfortable certainly got to be
reliable certainly got to be presentable
to the clients that's what they're
wanting and then they're giving you this
big car allowance but they do not pay
your car payment if they fire you and
you still have the car payment and they
did not require you to get a car payment
they did not require you to buy
brand-new those are rationalizations are
you used